yeah let me ask you something you you
have a girlfriend
I don't know so you're single I've been
single for a bit so um would you hook up
with girls when your do shows I have
yeah I have I mean it's it's tough
because when you're on tour for instance
you're only there for pretty much just a
couple hours like you have like a six
hour window to make it happen
you know yeah I I agree like when I'm
playing a week when I used to open for
guys you know and when I was single baby
last weekend but when you were when I
found out that I was doing a straight
week with Paulie in one place sure I'd
be like I think I can do it but when I
did when we did one-nighters it was
impossible because you would do the show
he would wrap the show up and then you'd
get on a bus right and you're off to the
next place is like no no you get nothing
true yeah
and I'm not a closer are you a closer
well this tour I'm coming in yeah I'm
headlining there's no I known as a
headliner right no in terms of when you
meet a girl how way closer way we repeat
that again was that when you open okay
let's say you're in a place for two days
uh-huh right you meet a girl the first
night right
how how long do you need you see close
the deal out I'm definitely more shy on
that and then people think you know what
I'm saying yeah like if they if they're
kind of moving that along then you know
it's gonna go down
but me I'm actually not even that
aggressive you know what I'm saying
right but I I'm aggressive in my head
like I want it you know but like I'm
just kind of shy like it's weird like so
if the ball is hit at you line you'll
grab it yeah if it's a way you won't
chase after it yeah I mean also depends
on like how how haha how good the body
the ball is right it does yeah right
sometimes they're so hot you spent you
you'll just do out days right I mean I
remember one time there was one girl and
I didn't guarantee
but I remember not sleeping at all
begging her at 6:00 in the morning right
you know I'm a sleeper yeah I love my
sleep yeah that was only one time baby
those will be 20 years ago I can't
imagine you begging I imagine you like
maybe just like praying in a corner and
just like looking at her and just
praying to God
Oh who we just can I just stick my
fingers in exactly smooth ways of
begging you know when you're begging you
don't you don't realize how desperate
you actually look so you're shy uh-uh in
a sense like I like if there's a girl
like at a bar and I think she's hot I
I'm not usually the guy who's just cold
car and let's walk up to her me like was
good like I need like a homie of mine to
kind of act a fool first right and then
I'm like uh but if they're a fan but if
they're a fan that that helps it helps
me yeah yeah would you date a fan
seriously I think it's tough I've
definitely been turned off sometimes
when they're like like too much of a fan
I don't know I and I've had that you
know even though the girls like super
hot or whatever because they're in love
with their perception of like your
persona basically they don't they it
would cloud it would get in the way of
really getting to know you know you they
have this like idea of like ooh maybe I
don't know what it is it's just I don't
know it's also you want um you also want
to chase a little bit that's what it is
then you need to chase if you don't have
the chase it just doesn't feel exciting
yeah you want to feel like you we're
you're you're catching something and
you're you're earning it earning it I
think most of the time that I've
definitely been involved with a girl
it's always been me chasing the girl
yeah it hasn't been like one girl that's
like really just been on mine it's
always me just liking the girl me
actually really trying to come
persistent yeah like flirtatious
constantly yeah yeah I'm not shy when it
comes to DMS yeah I think you I've ever
sent a dick pic I have yeah you have a
little cream did Corey come on
you know what it's something that I
don't do now but you have done it yeah
because I've been reckless I've been
drunk I've done lot of drugs you know
when I'm in that state I was like I
shouldn't have been doing that you know
what I'm saying right like it's a scary
thing because you're like nowadays
anybody could screenshot and stuff even
thinking back on those days I was like
what the was I thinking oh so do
you you did it before you were
dumbfounded actually no no no this was
when I was done found I'm like that's
why it's like I'm like ooh but I
shouldn't have been doing that yeah you
know so I mean if I did a dick pic yeah
send it to somebody unsolicited whether
we are we already flirting you and I
yeah yeah we're already flirting I'm
just talking about if there was just a
picture of my face and my dick it would
it would destroy the internet would
meltdown you would destroy the internet
it would it would be a disaster for away
a lot of people have seen your dick
though because you've done a lot of
shows where you like there's a
difference what's the showing your dick
for comedy purposes right is different
than showing your dick for sexual
purposes alright because for comedy I
want you to laugh at my dick but when
you're sending a dick pic you're not you
want some right it's like you're trying
to it's a it's a product that you're
representing as a salesman yeah what I
disagree about that is this I like being
you disagree to I think a lot of dudes
send dick pics more for themselves as
women we don't really see like we don't
look at a dick pic and we're like yeah
we're more like she saw my dick or I
could go the other way with sugar get
angry but I'm saying if they if they
don't get angry I'm all like that's a
victory you've never seen a dick pic and
one that's a beautiful dick I seen many
beautiful dicks I don't I I think that I
could probably look at it and be like
okay that's a penis but I don't I don't
feel sexual towards it right it's like
that last big thing where the guy showed
the lastik to me he shall be sent me
like three in his face wasn't it I was
like this put his face his profile was
not private yeah fearless
so relationship trust - you know cuz
couples send you know pictures of each
other all the time like girls you know
people I've been involved as if sent me
like nude 's and stuff I would never
like you know how does that last like
how long and how many years do you have
to be with somebody for it for the
sending nudes thing to stop I mean I'll
just because we have do not send each
other news it's like we said one word
text I'll just stop like bananas no in
the first couple years I think there was
like you would send me photos of
everything is newlywed kind of you
know like it's exciting but you're right
it will stop eventually yeah yeah are my
texts what there's like food now yeah
get it get it you know or like yes 7:45
he's gonna be here like you yeah like
you just direct right right you know
like we're working yeah yeah is he
allergic to cats
I mean we maybe we should start up again
I forced it I'm gonna send you a nude
and tell me if you feel anything at all
a good experiment or I'm willing to send
you a new doll so maybe I don't want to
we'll see that's work that's the problem
it's go both ways you try sending me a
dick pic and then I want to know I want
to see how I feel I'll do it now I'm not
going to show you now you see already
you know because that's not the
it's got to be hard babe oh oh it's got
to be hard yeah he does have to be hard
it's you know that rule is like a
half-chub usually really does this cuz
you want to look like like that's you
when you're not hard email anavar are so
right I'm actually more that was that
was interesting what you said you know
you always want them to have more like
wanting more that's why it's the half
sub you showed me like this is me when
yeah yeah I wonder what he's like when
he is are
you're right half chubs are a lot sexier
send me a half-chub but you're when
you're on the road not now that was just
half job babe so you want it kind of
hard but just kind of hanging on your
side just laying on you're taking a nap
all right but you're not gonna post it
you don't want it levitating I have so
many liked pictures why the would I
just don't post my have to have dick pic
on online I wouldn't do that with that
would that make a headline like would
that be on TMZ like but I think I would
be enjoyable here's the girlfriend he's
living with no but I think that like I
think that I don't think that you know
the show that I'm on coming out he's
gonna be happy about me having a dick
pic online yeah that's a good question
actually I was wondering you know
obviously couples and stuff send dick
pics each other or like nudes to each
other like nowadays would that be a
proper problematic thing if that got
exposed right you know what I'm saying
but yeah it's a different time to like
I'm sure there's less dick pics being
sent than ever
Yeah right now it's it really is a very
sensitive time and I just think anything
sexual should just be cut out of
everything for right now I'll tell you
you you make me wise you make that face
right now the most obvious but I'm
telling people not to have sex no I want
you to have sex guys I'm gonna be more
specific it's just that a little bit
more conscientious about things is what
the word I wanted to you thank you so
much yeah then let me clarify that too
sending dick pics to you know your
that's what I meant the whole time yes
just let me clarify that moving forward
and you know they're just you know I
just wanted to add to that I'm not gonna
I'm not saying anything what's gonna get
me in trouble okay baby I know you get
worried when I talk about this it's just
that you know I think at the end of the
day you know I'm just looking back at my
own behaviors is is that you know my
weird sexuality toward people have been
strictly based on comedy and never
through mean wanting to nut or get off
on it right and I think that that's the
line I agree because when it comes to
actually like
when like I said when we first started
hooking up he was so afraid like he's
really wild and naked and you know this
like idea of this like guy who's who
doesn't but when it comes to actually
closing the deal he's not he's you know
he's very like Oh am I allowed am I not
yeah I'm a lawyer I'm like a lawyer when
it comes I believe and very legal I mean
I think people kind of get that vibe
from you that it is comedic you know
what I'm saying yeah yeah but you know I
know a lot of guys right now I'm not
gonna name any names that um I was
talking to one guy who was pretty fame
I'm gonna say his name but he was like
yeah I slapped this girl's ass yeah it
would still like we're at a part I
slapped her ass just like a long time
ago a long time ago
and now I'm in big trouble for that mmm
you know and it's like yeah you don't
slap of strangers I have yeah that that
that takes a lot of like that you have
to turn time first let's suppose you're
drunk
and we're at a pool party it's the
dumbfounded pool party okay during the
summer right and I'm a really hot chick
I'm a big fan right I'm wearing a skimpy
bathing suit right and I walk by you and
go I love your last album whatever would
you slap her ass no I will I wouldn't
slap her ass but I have been situations
where like I got a home girl and she's
like twerking almost like there's a good
there's a good there's a good scenario
invite you I'm sitting there right a
girl twerking yeah like her just black
jiggly ass is in my face it's got to be
black I just cuz I give someone a chance
I let it create a no I don't even race
this but if you got a sound zone that
would just be bone okay
flat boney ass I don't want it what's
black jiggly you know me in my face why
it sounded fair I want to go I want to
slap it right do you is if I slapped a
jiggly ass in my face
that's twerking like hella thousand not
a thousand that's a tough thing you know
what I'm saying like ya know that's a
tough thing to call you know it could
come someone could get mad you know I'm
saying I knew my home
girl I know like you know she'd be
turning up and you know yeah doing the
strip right that's why I was like that's
like a really night early 90s male
chauvinist thing to do like to just slap
an ass of a stranger yeah very Mad Men
that's so wash yeah no yeah that's
that's another thing that is why
so yeah just keep your hands to yourself
but it's also this is that like I don't
ever want to be in a sexual situation
with somebody that doesn't want to be in
it with me right so it's like I know a
lot of guys like I know she don't like
me but I'm gonna pursue it because I
want I want to have it right now that
mentality it's like no if you don't
think that I'm cute and you think you
don't think that I'm attractive I don't
want to do it mmm I don't touch you
because that's like then it's weird and
creepy yeah I don't why don't guys have
that thing and that's the that's a
tricky question too cuz there's dudes
who are just like I'm gonna like her
hard you know like I'm gonna win her
over eventually win her over you know
and sometimes it does happen
no I yeah but you do it through not just
slapping around do it by showing them
your soul and sewing them who you are
yeah but sometimes is it like a dude
doing too much wondered like constantly
texting and you know what I'm saying
because they're trying to you know win
her over
yeah because that could be that is
little aggressive too you know like I
ain't not to be totally unattractive and
he's just doing too much it's such a
turn-off you're like give me space and
time to breathe it's like a cake
put me or like baking something put me
in there alone I need time to like rise
and
[Music]